we wanted to make a real character
someone of that you could look into when
you felt this isn't a costume that this
is a real person early on we were
thinking how do we re skin these worlds
with these kind of hellish elements and
we wanted to have our own looking
without it being too cliche a world that
is full of life full of movement is very
vivid and when I think in hell blade we
can take that in a direction that's a
bit darker than what we've done before
hell blade is ninja theory's new project
and it's an independent Triple A game so
we can have complete creative control of
the game and design it in such a way
that it's focused specifically on our
fans and our supporters and it's going
to be focused really on three things and
that's melee combat a deep engaging
character story and on our unique art
vision hell blade is about taking those
to the next level
it's based on Celtic history and biking
history they uncovered a Celtic goddess
1600 years ago in England I named Salwa
we don't know anything about her there's
some inscription there but that's all
you are I'm being patient this history
that must have been in that character is
just unknown so that in itself was
interesting but then to create a
character that wasn't your typical sexy
heroin we've been trying to work against
that trying to make her more real more
like she lived in that time and period I
think it signals the kind of more
maturity in our way of thinking and I
think that fits in with where we see
technology going it's become more mature
the worlds that we can create seem more
real the characters need to feel more
real we need to fight against the CG
look
and kind of put things that are
difficult to do in the game like dirt
and fur and hair and although it's still
very fantastical it's got a different
twist on fantasy that's much more based
on on her her inner eye and how she sees
the world it's like her personal descent
into hell is reflected in the world it's
more of an inner journey
hi
it's her biggest fears and nightmares
kind of manifested in a visual language
and that's kind of super exciting on we
want to take advantage of a lot of post
to work for that but also a lot of
effects work and that's that's where
that's what I'm most excited about is to
really not just have it as a cool effect
but to tell a story with these elements
inhale blowed we wanted the world to
feel more like that you've been dropped
into this island area and initial tests
were done where we've got the logo for
hell blade we've not shoe Honda the logo
in there it's there's natural elements
and this subtle kind of man-made
features that when you do pull out you
begin to read that so we started by
putting the logo in and using some
negative and positive space and trying
to just quickly rough out what the this
kind of volcanic circle could look like
with the heart of the city the eye in
the center and then just very quickly
got that into unreal for dropping
ourselves onto the mountains and looking
back at the whole kind of circle of the
logo and and then imagining well that
looks like these little spines coming
through the water and that could be rock
and this could be marshall and and so
this new approach of drawing on
strengths that we see and then making
features within those seems to be
working really well at the moment
we want it to be the most realistic game
done and unreal engine will definitely
help support that you know people with
all of their leaps forward with the
physical based shading and the dynamic
lighting it's definitely going to be a
really visual feast and a great journey
to go through to see our interpretation
of help
you